um for people who aren't from La
obviously you have rolling 40s 4S
tattooed on your on your lip people who
can't read it um I think that the most
famous [__] from La in the last decade
is probably nip who is you know
obviously is affiliated with the Rolland
60s um are you guys like very what's the
difference between the roll 40s rolling
the 60s and well it's kind of like [__]
it's kind of like the same thing like
the 40s well in LA and the hoods like
that's going to be like the closest
hoods going to get to like damn and
there being the same it's like only a
couple shits off from us being different
like we like anything that's got like
rolling in front of it it's kind of like
n cuz like rolling 30s rolling hundreds
all type of [__] but just the 40s and
the 60s cuz we just like we just like it
just been always you kind of moveing the
same direction type [__] on gang so we
just like all acted like 40s and the 60s
on gang same Ops same Ops that makes
sense okay um was nip somebody who you
grew up like you know looking up to not
necessarily looking up to cuz but I had
like a on the day homies a couple uh nip
songs I used to play on gang I ain't
going to lie I play I I listen to C more
after fyp but I think the world was like
that I mean I mean I've known nip since
09 he was on my show in 09 but like you
know unfortunately he passed away and
then people really gave him the flow he
deserved after he maybe like look at
certain [__] different and pay attention
to his lyrics a little bit more on G but
like yeah I had a couple songs like that
that was hot though that I used to play
while he was
alive I didn't like you know look up to
him though but he was like on the day Me
a Genius though no for sure one of the
greats man I was like I wonder too like
it's it's crazy cuz I feel like um him
passing the way he did like you know was
such a tragic situation cuz he was at
home like for you do you see [__] like
that and like make sure you're kind of
like very very careful cuz now you got a
lot of eyes on you bro yeah hell yeah on
the dead homies bro i' be like paranoid
cuz I'll be already like moving a
certain way though on the D homies I
don't like being a certain place too
long I be like in and out I like cuz I
already know [__] like that can happen I
already know and you're very
recognizable I'm very recognizable
everybody already know me your face
tattoos are very I mean yeah people
people see you know you you don't know
them they could [__] around call they
can be like an innocent looking type
[__] you don't even know see you like
oh that's X4 [__] around text T4 up here
you don't even know crazy [__] like that
so you're always in and out of places
hell yeah you got to be in and out bro
you'll die or [__] around in up in a
situation where you got to kill a [__]
now you fight life yeah I know is like a
lot of people like you know for the most
part
La if you're it feels like if you're if
you're doing what you're supposed to be
doing you're successful in any sort of
way like you just get more hate you know
what I'm saying and not even necessarily
from like who your quote unquote Ops
should be like people from where you're
from yeah hell yeah cuz everybody like
you know they want to be the one they Be
Like That Should Be Me That Should Be Me
type [__] cuz so that's how that should
be and it they always say like if
somebody ask you for something you can
say yes 10 times when you say no on the
11th time they take that [__] personal
in that there tell a [__] no that's
that's who you that's they going to
expose what it really is 100% have you
uh had to weed out any of those type of
people around your Camp cuz obviously
like you said like you got you know you
you got you said ex-manager you know so
like have you had to kind of like filter
out any of your immediate circle hell
yeah on the dead homies not really be on
it now on the Dead Homie cuz it's really
like getting serious now so I really
like be antenna's high I really be on
[__] I ain't got time for no to keep my
grass cut anybody that do any type of
bunk snake Vibes get up out of here um
what's what's uh wack involvement with
your career nothing he just like give me
advice and [__] he just called me the
other day too and just told me like you
know I'm [__] high he just like proud of
me and all that type of [__] great guy
that love wack man I can always like
call him for advice and [__] yeah yeah
whack's a good guy yeah I've been on the
um wrong end of a screaming whack call
before was that right in 2000 was it
2015 yeah shout out to Wack he thought I
leaked a song a game song which I didn't
leak well [__] I'll probably react the
same way I somebody my song I was living
in Florida at something like yo what how
the [__] I got the soong bro like I'm
living in Florida dog
like he was he's like I have my team of
hackers and they know that you're the
one that leaked it and I'm like bro what
what what hackers you got dog hey but
then he's got these Clubhouse detectives
you never know [__] it's crazy um man
hey which tattoo hurt the
most uh this one right here cuz I got
this [__] picked in jail cuz oh
so it was like like pick I got to sit
there and get that [__] like
little line yeah I got to re hit again
when I got out but the originally that's
kind of how they would be doing that
[__] in like uh the old days right hell
yeah so what is it what what do they use
is it a needle like yeah like a little
needle cuz on the D really like a little
staple a staple it's like a staple cup
but they make it as you know in jail cuz
all type of creative smart ass peoplez
You' be surprised no no for sure I saw
them doing Habachi in jail so [__]
like staple cut guitar string or
whatever on the D homies and they put it
on rap it however the [__] rap it do
what they do do [__] are they like make
a get some batteries whever the [__]
connect that up to make that run how
that run and do what they do [__] great
that sounds terrible on gang how many of
your tattoos did you get in jail uh most
of them most of them yeah damn did was I
I always you know my cousins are all in
prison and uh they are all fully
tattooed and they would always be like
you know the guys who could do tattoos
in prison like they're kind of like a
hot commodity you know what I'm saying
like yeah H yeah CU everybody be wanting
to get tatted and [__] so everybody
wants to get tatted so you kind of like
gotta you know slide them some some food
or you know some bread on the outside
whatever it is you know the tatan area
hell yeah you going make you going to
run it up you can run it up in jail [__]
off a lot of [__] you can run it up off
a lot of [__] in jail [__] how do they
get phones in
jail the guards
usually who knows yeah I we don't we
don't we don't want to blow up the spot
yeah no I get it I get it I get it know
yeah I I always wonder is the service
terrible
though uh it depends on like where you
at like what jail you at like if you got
Metro PCS are you
[__] I ain't even like seen no Metro
PCS like you get like an obamaphone in
jail you're like bro like we're in
[__] concrete walls there's no
service yeah it'd be like you know AT&T
Verizon [__] like that damn uh I seen
Sprint before like Sprint yeah I I can
only imagine like that would be a
necessity it's like you got to figure
out how to get a phone like because
otherwise you'd be going [__] crazy
or just reading every book in the
[__] [__] you got to learn how to
jail without a phone though cuz there
going to be certain situations and
certain environments where you don't
have you a got no phone you're not
supposed to have the phone Contra yeah
that sh Contraband cuz what was your
longest bit it was four years four years
what were like uh out of was that prison
or County or what was that well year was
in County then three years in prison and
like depending on where you're at like
obvious I heard I heard LA County Jail
was it LA County yeah I heard that well
6 months in AI County then 6 months LA
county and then 3 years agil I heard LA
county is like the absolute worst place
to be I mean yeah depending on the type
of a person you is just like let's say
me or him go to LA County are we [__]
no you straight I heard it's rough in
there man n you'll be straight but you
got to run with the white boys though so
you going to be under a certain type of
program though you got to be kind of
racist not not kind of racist cuz but
it's going to be certain type of rules
that you going to have to follow and if
you don't follow them then they going to
have to what are the rules well it's
different rules cuz so like let's say
you and our homies right I'm in jail but
I got to run with the whites can you and
I have lunch no damn not County now we
can't eat together cuz it's for like
y'all that y'all got to follow type [__]
but us like we like do what we like want
to do type [__] well there's some white
boys that end up going fall y fall no
y'all fall under meican when when y go
in there so y going to have to do like y
fall under they program when y go to
county jail so you got to wake up at a
certain time do certain [__] you know
that's how I go that's the jail what if
I just want to hang out just be alone
you know you can just hang out be alone
right there in the day right there we
can chop it up talking [__] but I'm
saying like what if I don't want to roll
with the whites what if I just want to
be alone can you be alone walk in there
and say you other but you got to just
make sure your whole career go like that
you got to walk in every dorm and from
your whatever you I'm saying like
obviously I'm white but if I'm like hey
guys like whatever y'all got going on
that's fine I just want to sit in myself
C and read is that a possibility well if
you go in there and say you other then
you can do what the [__] you want to do
but what does other mean that mean just
other other race other like Hawaiian or
[__] Asian Asian you going there say
you other then sh now you fall under
black card now you know now you got you
got more lency to do white boys that end
up following under the black car y seen
some some white boys that I thought was
white whole time he black like Muslims
all type of [__] what about there's some
there's some Mexicans too right they go
yeah some means have fall on their black
car too Jesus yeah man listen you should
never go back all right we got to make
sure you never go back you got too much
to you got too much to lose now yeah I'm
out trophied up CU I'm out know cu